Nên em lắm thành sau, tổng thống mì đô đàn trăm tiền đồ hồ Washington sẽ đáp trả bằng tổng vụ sức mạnh quân sử,
nếu Iran thật hiện bất kỳ hành động tình công nào nhằm bà lỡ a cúmi đại trúng đông.
Ông nhân mạnh, nếu mì bị Iran tổng vực giới bất kỳ hi tức nào, Iran sẽ phải hứng chiếu một cuộc trường phạt quân sử chua tình thấy,
trên bố đứa đưa ra trong bố cảnh Isheran Tiền Hành trên dịch không quyết quý mối lớn
và hủ khoảng 1 trong nămu yếu tại Iran bà gồm chú sở bộ cuo phòng, cơ sình hạnh nhân và cá mỏ rộ khi,
nhà trắng hợp định Mỹ không tham gia tử dịch này, những ông trăm thường nhát Washington đã bị chất kể hỏi và cùng có phố trở phòng thu, cho Isheran,
ông cá ngồi chính dịch của Isheran là tuyệt bơi và cho biết Mỹ vẫn sợ sàng đồng vai trò chung dân hò dài,
nếu cả hai bên chức nhận đối thoại, phía Iran lập tức đáp trả mạnh cách phòng tư lừa vào nhiều cơ sở năng lượng và tiền tiếp tế như liệu cho tìm kích Isheran,
ngoài trử Iran ông á bà s'arocchi tố cao Isheran VF, lập pháp của tế và cho biết, nước này của bằng trường Mỹ hỗ trợ chính dịch,
càng báo sẽ không loại trường hành động của sự trực tiếp, nếu Mỹ tết tục càng dự,
các thằng khiến vòng đàn phản thân, Mỹ Iran dự kiến tổ chức tại ông mang ngày 11h xa ổ đại bị vi bò,
trong một động tháng ngoài rao đàn truyền, tổng thống Trump tì lộ, ông đã điện đàn với tổng thống ngào,
b let me put in tụng ngài, hai nhà lệ nạo nước chi, cần sớm, chấm chất xuống đồ dự Iran,
và mở lại cân đàn phát hành nhân. ngoài ra, cũng có thông tin cho thấy Mỹ đang ấm thầm tay bụi chi lức
dựa tại Trung Đông, chuẩn bị sẵn sẵn đối phó với New Year's Day,
cũng được khu vật ngày càng lãn giống và khó kinh xuất.